where is his plan to democrats mitch
mcconnell is gridlock personified the
lawmaker single-handedly standing in the
way of the obama agenda our top
political priority over the next two
years should be to deny president obama
a second term but to some conservatives
mcconnell is a sellout an establishment
republican still too willing to cut
deals with democrats but we're certainly
not going to send the signal
to the markets and to the american
people
that default
is an option but even mcconnell's
critics concede he is a master political
strategist a survivor now poised to
become majority leader if republicans
can gain a net of six seats in the
senate and if he can overcome a spirited
challenge from a democrat less than half
his age he's a senator that's out of
touch
out of ideas
and with the help of west kentucky will
be out of time on november 4th
helped by bill and hillary clinton
allison lundergan grimes has taken aim
at mcconnell for months kentucky
mitch
that's not how you hold a gun
blaming him for dc's dysfunction senator
mcconnell's 30-year record it's gridlock
it's obstruction it's extreme
partisanship that's cost this nation a
weekend poll put mcconnell up nine
points even though 49 percent of likely
voters view him unfavorably the good
news for mcconnell president obama is
even less popular his main message
kentuckians will benefit from his
promotion the majority leader gets to
set the agenda not only for the country
but to look out for kentucky's interest
so one of the basic questions here is
who can do the most for kentucky over
the next six years mcconnell took no
chances at the end loaning his campaign
1.8 million dollars for the final push
tonight he'll find out if he's on his
way to a sixth term and the most
powerful job in the u.s senate peter
cook bloomberg washington